ce que la pandémie a frappé nos
restaurants ont été des premiers et les
plus durement affectées les
restaurateurs s'attendent à voir bientôt
une vague massive de fermeture la
chambre de commerce du canada s'appuie
sur une enquête réalisée par statistique
canada pour dire que jusqu'à 60 % des
restaurants pourraient être obligées de
fermer d'ici la fin de l'automne
c'est ce qui motive d'ailleurs le
lancement de la campagne nos restaurants
les entreprises de restauration font un
appel au public comme au gouvernement
pour maintenir leur industrie à flot et
citant deux restaurants fermés et bien
ça entraînerait bien sûr des pertes
d'emplois partout au pays
mais quelles seraient les conséquences
des répercussions l'axé fermeture dans
le mode dans le monde agricole où il en
parle avec maurice doyon agro économiste
et professeur à l'université laval
bonjour monsieur doyon
mais je suis d'abord face à la pandémie
comme le pays s'est mis en quelque sorte
en pause au moins quelques semaines ça
dû entraîner déjà des ajustements dans
le monde agricole quels sont ils
oui c'était c'était quand même un choc
donc il ya eu des demandes comme on l'a
vu supplémentaires dans les épiceries
avec un transport quitte apple tu peux
la lentille donc eu des problèmes pour
certains produits et liliana chérie donc
les hôtels les restaurants et puis les
institutions tout cela demande a baissé
de ce côté là donc dû y avoir des
réajustements par exemple au niveau des
quantités surpasse au fromage donc des
demandes pour li la grande restauration
qui qui n'existait plus ou qui étaient
drôlement diminué donc ça a eu des
répercussions à très court terme
et si 60% des restaurants fermés
justement comme le chiffre lancé par la
chambre de commerce du canada quels
seraient les impacts pour les
producteurs agricoles par exemple patti
y ait plusieurs les posteurs agricole
comme comme on le voit dans la cage vide
tout le monde n'est pas égal là dedans
donc pour les producteurs agricoles qui
sont qui ont visé des produits très
nicher par exemple qui font affaire
directement que des restaurateurs que
c'est leur principal débouché dans la
région de québec ont en eu
particulièrement peur c'est bien entendu
que pour russe et
de notre côté on débute par des millions
se disait pour ceux qui ont de
l'agrotourisme et qui vendent
directement aux consommateurs
on croyait que ça allait très mauvais
mais semble-t-il avec le tourisme que
l'on eut au québec mining québécois qui
se sont promenés ça a été semble-t-il
une très très bonne année pour la
majorité d'entre donc des gagnants est
clairement il ya des perdants et quels
sont les secteurs peut-être qu'ils sont
les plus perdant dans tout ça c'est pas
bon mais souvent les dix acteurs qui ont
compris considéré comme étant peut-être
un petit peu plus à la marche exercer
c'est pas lui le secteur laitier ou la
volaille tous ses pôles et les grands
secteurs mais des producteurs qui
faisait peut-être une volaille très
spécialisés ou ou encore des producteurs
qui faisant un produit un peu différent
pour urs à peu à être un petit peu plus
difficile
l'ensemble des producteurs agricoles ont
dit ont subi des ajustements et soute
mais je pense que les choses sont en
voie de se rétablir pour la majorité des
agriculteurs mais comme je vous ai
encore une fois certains dans d'autres
groupes auront gagné et d'autres ont
perdu
on n'est pas nécessairement visé lorsque
ce que je vous explique c'est pas
nécessairement relatifs à une production
mais c'est plutôt une façon de faire une
façon de mettre en marché leurs produits
justement vous évoquez l'agrotourisme
qui a eu le vent dans les voiles
est ce que bon certains l'ont déjà fait
pour cet été
craignez que ça ne fonctionne pas bien
est-ce que plusieurs producteurs
pourraient justement en profiter pour
réorienter leur entreprise en termes
agrotouristique justement c'est sûr que
la localisation est important dans tous
les producteurs agricoles du québec ne
peuvent pas faire de l'agrotourisme on
s'entend pour ceux qui avaient des
produits très riche et il est possible
qu'ils tentent de se réorienter vers une
vente directe au consommateur avec une
visité mais on s'entend que c'est quand
même
c'est plus la même entreprise donc c'est
ça c'est des changements significatifs
que les promeneurs ou faire c'est des
ajustements oui donc le certains
certainement vont y passer et ils vont
le faire c'est peut-être déjà commencé
mais tout le monde n'est pas
nécessairement de faire l'autre idée du
jour vraiment en fait l'autre idée au
goût du jour là c'est l'autosuffisance
est-ce que ça c'est un objectif qui est
réalisable à court terme d'après vous je
parlerai pas de tout suffisant ce sens
pour ça mais est ce que est ce qu'il est
possible d'augmenter la compte le
contenu québécois dans notre cas
certainement
certainement on a la capacité de
produire en serre de façon beaucoup plus
significatif que l'on compte fait
présentement est justement des
discussions avec hydro québec
le gouvernement a donné 1 1 ça semble
poussif à tout le moins pour qu'on nous
serriculteurs puisse obtenir des tarifs
préférentiels
donc on pouvait voir un essor de la de
la production en serre au québec ce qui
lui montrait potentiellement aussi le
pourcentage de produits québécois dans
notre assiette
un peu comme enlever avec les fermes lui
faire apprendre qu'ils prennent encore
de l'expansion maurice voyante
merci beaucoup merci au revoir